it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro khanna who
represents california's 17th district uh
congressman you know i have to say over
the last three months there has sort of
been new life breathed into the biden
administration and joe biden a number of
legislative accomplishments
he seems significantly more energetic
arguably one of the most productive
covid isolation periods of anyone i can
think of
joe biden had a couple of months ago do
you get the sense that this will impact
november's midterms for democrats in the
house like you or that these are really
uh siloed accomplishments that that the
biden administration is experiencing
there is sense of momentum and that's
because democrats are delivering the
president delivered student debt relief
we're bringing manufacturing back to
america with the semiconductor bill that
i led with chips in science we are have
the largest investment in climate in
american history so there's a sense that
what the president said he would do what
we said we would do in 2020 we are doing
uh and
that is finally breaking through and
there's also a sense that the democratic
party is more unified than we've been
probably since the beginning of the
president's term yeah that that seems
absolutely to be taking place and when
you particularly contrast to what's
happening in the republican party where
the rnc is stopping paying trump's legal
bills and you're seeing um significant
disagreements
on what the 2024 republican nomination
should look like and whether the
presence of people like liz cheney is
even
remotely welcome it does seem like there
is a significantly more unification
among the democratic party
and also on some issues there seems to
be disagreement i mean the student loan
debt relief is an example where you have
some who believe even on the democratic
side there should be no such debt relief
at all people decided to take out these
loans and they should pay the loans on
the other hand individuals who say all
student loan debt should be forgiven and
then folks kind of in the middle who say
well some some debt relief is a good
idea where are you on further debt
relief
i'm forgetting debt relief up to fifty
thousand i mean the reality is uh ten
thousand dollars is often what it costs
someone to do one semester at a college
or one year at a community college it's
not enough but i applaud the president
for taking a major step
this is going to help a lot of working
and middle class folks it is again a
precedent for doing more so i want to
applaud him but say that the job is not
done on the manufacturing jobs
explain to us exactly how one brings a
job back to the united states
from overseas where that will increase
the total cost to produce whatever is
being produced without making inflation
worse like what's the economic sequence
wherein we can do that
well actually producing more things in
the united states could help long-term
with inflation i mean one of the reasons
we had inflation is we didn't make masks
here we didn't make semiconductors here
so you had to ship them from overseas at
fifteen thousand dollars shipping per
container as opposed to two thousand
dollars and the fact that we didn't have
enough production uh meant that we had
too much money chasing too few goods if
you increase production long term uh
that is deflationary but you're saying
in a micro case well how are you going
to produce it here when wages may be
higher when environmental standards may
be higher i think that's why you need
both government collaboration in terms
of financing i mean other countries have
helped finance new factories new
industries government support on
the workforce development at community
colleges
and a a collective regional economic
development effort that's what we did
with fdr to build our economy and
there's no reason we can't do it now
yeah i mean i guess the shipping is
certainly a factor but 15 000 versus two
for a shipping container
paying dramatically lower wages on every
unit on an ongoing basis seems like it
would be it would override the shipping
cost i mean i guess it depends on the
product and we'd have to sort of look at
the details but it seems also there
probably has to be some shift in the
thinking from the american
public about the advantages to domestic
manufacturing as well and and i don't
know that the messaging is really there
on that
well i'm not sure it requires a change
in consumer behavior obviously it'd be
great to to buy american but you could
have government purchasing american with
all the purchasing power we have that
would make a difference uh second a lot
of the advanced manufacturing
has uh much less labor cost because of
automation
it has increased productivity now people
say well this means less jobs which is
true but those are going to be higher
paying jobs and it's going to mean more
competitiveness for the product so i
think when it comes to advanced
manufacturing interval interwoven
textiles for example as opposed to
traditional manufacturing that can be
done here and will be done here and the
quality is often higher here uh that's
not just an opinion the productivity of
american workers is more than germany uh
or japan and so i think we have to be
very deliberate about the type of
production that can be done uh the
government uh partnership that is
required uh and we can do it in a way
that is cost competitive yeah you know
one one uh high-tech product that is
being manufactured at least partially in
the united states is tesla electric
vehicles and it's been very interesting
to see that many on the right you would
think as i outlined yesterday they
should love electric vehicles you can
charge them at home with solar panels
you own and not be right there's the
self-sufficiency aspect to it for people
who like fast cars which are associated
with alpha males in some right-wing
circles electric vehicles are very fast
there's all these reasons why the right
should really be embracing electric
vehicles and yet
they seem almost angry about them to
some degree your colleague marjorie
taylor greene and many others are
furious about electric vehicles
are you surprised by the antipathy
towards them from some on the right
i'm not because unfortunately climate
has become so politicized that anything
that is almost good for the climate uh
generates uh skepticism uh on the right
and that's why i think we could just
talk about the new industrialization of
america let's build the new industries
new factories here it turns out a lot of
that will be clean a lot of that is
going to be clean steel new batteries
new electric vehicles new charging
station hydrogen jets hydrogen planes
we can talk about building new factories
new industry new manufacturing and that
may
cut across the uh the the political uh
divide
on uh on cannabis decriminalization you
and i have spoken about this before
my sense has been it's never been a
particularly interesting uh topic for
president joe biden but at the same time
i didn't think he was going to do any
student loan debt relief and i was very
very much wrong there do you get any
sense that there may be something before
november on cannabis from
the oval office
i don't you know i obviously am not just
for decriminalizing it i'm taking for
taking it off schedule c for legalizing
uh marijuana uh but uh i i think this is
something that's personal for the
president my understanding is that he
has had people
with substance abuse in his own family
that that is informing his view it's
obviously a view that i uh
disagree with but because it's something
that
seems to be a
sincerely held conviction on his part
one that i disagree with i'm not sure
that uh we're going to see movement on
that
do you expect that on the in the long
term
the cannabis issue is going to be dealt
with more at the state level as it has
been so far or that at some point there
will be a federal change
i think it's going to start at the state
level but uh my sense is within the next
uh
couple cycles presidential cycles
there'll be a federal change because you
have people on the republican side
the younger generation that understands
the importance of uh
legalizing cannabis and the medical uses
and the fact that uh cannabis often is
less
uh dangerous certainly less dangerous
than the opioids uh and yet more
restricted than some of the opioids
um let's talk a little bit about the
upcoming midterms so if we want to take
just one forecast the 538 forecast says
it's roughly a two to one chance that
democrats hold the senate
and by a roughly four to one margin
democrats are likely to lose the house
now on the house some of the recent
momentum you mentioned is not really in
those numbers quite yet but it's a
pretty significant hill to climb at this
point and sort of the most
mathematically likely outcome is a
divided congress it seems to me
that this will be two years of total
republican obstruction to prevent any
major legislation and then using the
lack of accomplishments that they cause
as justification to vote for a
republican president in 2024 that seems
to be that what the game plan is going
to be are you and your colleagues
talking about that as the most likely
outcome and what what can be done if
anything
well we're still hopeful that we can
hold a house especially after new york
19 and uh the surprising result there
where pat ryan wasn't expected to win uh
abort he really ran on abortion rights
we're
seeing as you know increased
registration among young women in
particular uh in ohio in pennsylvania so
are we underdogs to hold a house yes of
course the president's party always
loses seats we're in a tough economic
climate but we're still focused on how
we do that
and the argument that we're making to to
be able to do that
is where is the republican agenda i mean
uh we have an agenda i can tell you what
we will do on inflation we're going to
try to get child care done we're going
to uh make sure that we uh are providing
greater uh benefits for for medicare
we're going to increase the social
security we're going to produce more
things in
america the republicans have no
agenda they're basically just running uh
anti-uh uh biden yeah it's basically
just obstruct there's no doubt about
that but that nonetheless if they
successfully do that for two years
it's not a super strong argument for
democrats to say well yes we got nothing
done but it wasn't our fault i mean it
just it doesn't sound like the type of
thing that voters will buy so what do
you do if that does end up being the
situation
well it depends i mean obviously
president obama and president clinton
had obstructionist republican congresses
that both won re-election and they did
it by showing just how extreme uh the
republican congresses were right so it
depends on uh whether the republicans
overplay their hand which they're very
capable of doing i mean if all they're
doing when they take uh power is trying
to impeach joe biden and do hearings on
hunter biden and all the other
conspiracy theories uh then i think the
american public will tire off that and
say we need more reasonable people uh i
i
in the past when they've had the
majority they have overreached so
there's no reason to think they wouldn't
do that again
yeah that laptop from hell is really
something congressman we've got to we've
got to look at that hard drive
especially um last thing i want to ask
about how much in the
among your colleagues is their
discussion of the mar-a-lago search
warrant and just the you know 60 truth
social posts a day from the former
president like something is very very
wrong over there how much does that play
in the day-to-day between you and your
colleagues and sort of uh considering
that side of what's taking place in as
you think about your 2022 campaign and
then moving beyond 22 or is it wholly
irrelevant to what you and your
colleagues are doing
well we've tried
not to talk about it that much because
it's a law enforcement matter and we've
actually tried not to politicize it i
mean the last thing you want is uh every
democratic member of congress going on
cnn or your podcast giving an opinion on
what the justice department should do
right that said what does come up uh are
the threats frankly uh that colleagues
are facing uh in this environment and
they're more than i've ever seen in six
years you had uh eric swalwell post
yesterday about the threat he received
one of his staffers received uh really
ugly things and unfortunately i'm
hearing that kind of
threats and violence much more from
colleagues
which is concerning
are there
i mean obviously we i don't want you to
share what's being done but is there a
different or more
involved sort of security apparatus that
is that is now involved because of this
there is but you can't
protect in an open democracy uh
everyone from a culture of violence i
mean look members of congress uh we we
are in parades i was just in the pride
parade in san jose we are we do town
halls with hundreds of people we sit in
coffee shops and that's how it's
supposed to be uh and for
many many decades
people did that at both parties without
really worrying
about political violence i mean
obviously you had
crazy shootings and mass shootings but
those were one-off incidents now you're
at a point where there are members of
congress unfortunately who will be
advised to sit out a town hall or a
parade or community events and this is a
one of the real damages that doesn't get
talked about enough in our democracy
that the right is causing which is this
uh
fear of being connected to people yeah
and sadly the sort of
growing belief among some
that violence is an acceptable way to
try to achieve political change or to
make your opinions known which is really
scary and that goes to the gun culture
aspect as well right seeing guns as a
legitimate tool to solve interpersonal
problems
you know when i was growing up the the
one thing almost a cliche was while in
america we solve our political problems
without violence we have a peaceful
transfer of power i mean everyone would
say that is sort of pointing to why
we're the greatest democracy and it's
sad to me that something uh that basic
is now being
being questioned fortunately uh we still
uh are in a relatively peaceful place
and these are threats and they haven't
become full for full-born uh
assassination attempts but in other
countries you know you literally have uh
political parties trying to
assassinate
each other and we've got to be very
careful that we don't cross into a line
where violence becomes condoned
as part of the political culture yeah we
don't want to we don't want to end up
there and lindsey graham earlier this
week getting dangerously close to that
but we'll leave that for for another
conversation uh we've been speaking with
democratic congressman ro khanna who
represents california's 17th district
always a pleasure having you on
thank you really appreciate it